the institutional powers have declared
joe biden the winner
that's so irresponsible
this is crazy jake tapper responded to
trump trump said something like
you know we're suing or whatever jake
tapper said
donald trump's refusal to accept the
loss
you know blah blah and i'm just like for
jake tapper this
per this this high profile personality
on cnn to completely disregard the
constitution
is just like one of the most dangerous
things a media personality can do
either the guy is really really dumb or
he's
it's malicious so is jake tapper trying
to purposefully undermine the
constitution and our system of
governance
the idea that we have an election and
then that night we go we know who won
is just a tradition getting to the point
where i don't care if he
knows he's undermining the constitution
or not he is he's undermining the
constitution right
at some point in our history probably
with the invention of tv or maybe even
radio
we stopped saying the official results
will be announced on the 14th
and we started saying this is it we know
who won and so and so conceded
well that's fine and i got no problem
with that but donald trump didn't
concede
so the race isn't over we don't know
who's won we don't know which slate of
electors will be going to dc for their
you know formal
election it's not happened yet so for
the media to be saying all this stuff is
completely
spitting on the constitution and saying
we don't care about the process
it's a fact that trump is supposed to be
filing legal claims up until like the
eighth of december it's in in the
constitution for this reason these are
safeguards
to prevent you know fraud or impropriety
or whatever
so trump's allowed to do it and the
media doesn't like it they don't like
the fact that
he has the right to challenge it they're
flexing
uh they want to see how far their
influence can i mean even back when
obama
they had no reason to complain during
the obama years
during bush i remember i was oh he was
blowing up kids so they were happy you
know
well i mean all right so when we were
we're about the same age i think when we
were in high school
they were just making fun of bush all
the time then 911 happened and they
you know started the wars and all that
stuff and they kept criticizing bush
criticizing bush
calling him names making fun of him fine
they were
swinging their influence around just to
say like hey look we're controlling
the we're the mediators between the
people and the
uh governing bodies whatever so they'll
believe whatever we
say we whatever we tell them to believe
a journalist
let's say is in a position where i'll
listen to the journalists more than i'll
listen to a politician and trump is the
first time where the people are
listening to the politicians so closely
at least for in our generation they're
listening they're going directly to the
source there's no more middleman so the
middleman
cnn and all those people are feeling
themselves lose power
so they have to make it seem like this
is an emergency guys
my connection to you is like my psychic
link to you is being weakened
you need my words of wisdom in your ear
don't listen to that man who you have to
feel it's like that time
when the um when hillary's emails linked
uh leaked and then the
i can't remember who was it tapper or
was it judo you can't read them
yeah it's a legal eagle only we can read
that one
you have to it's like bro it's like in
the old church
like way in the old days the priests
would be like you can't read the bible
yourself i have to interpret it for you
i'll tell you what the bible says so
maybe he's fudging what the bible really
says
but then when the printing press was
invented and now the commoners can read
the bible it's like wait
this is what the bible says bro i gotta
give you how much money right
the internet really is like the printing
press all over again right and of course
the
the the priest equivalents of today
let's say cnn are now realizing oh shoot
uh
the common person can go directly to the
source of power without
me filtering the words filtering what i
want reality to be
they feel themselves losing power and
they the only way to
get people's attention again is to
create a crisis
you have to listen to what i have to say
it's so important
don't listen to the other guy well to
quote chancellor suttler
i want them to know why they need us
yeah who's he
from v for vendetta um i want it on the
interlink every story whatever you know
you have to it's like i get up in the
morning what should i do today what
should i be worried about
i should tune in to cnn and make sure
it's safe to go outside
even even me coming here i'm not going
to say specifics but it's like
i didn't even know what route to take
because
is is this place covid infested which
where's the safe direction to go am i
asking cnn did you turn on cnn and say
oh anderson please
i punched it into the intertron oh yes
and it's like
did you find the answer i did because
this is such a remote location actually
a spirit guide
oh you showed me on an eagle i followed
the face and the moon appeared and
looked down and said turn left because
google maps gonna start putting covet
friendly zones on your
they already do so what really i was
going every time i go to the doctor
they're like covered 19 alert cover 19
alert you have to have a mask
like is it like some of the roads are
green when there's covid in that area
like that this area has the miasma don't
go yeah yeah
do you guys see the uh ticketmaster is
saying that they're going to put your
vaccination status in the ticket or
whatever
oh jeez goodbye ticketmaster okay no
all right the nosebleed section will be
the uh the dirty people
who didn't take it exactly they're not
gonna let you in no i think what's gonna
end up happening is
you know if they made fun of
anti-vaxxers for a long time now they're
saying anti-maskers
because it's meant to be like you know
like similar and so right now they're
saying dude just wear the mask man it's
not a big deal and even though i'm
saying it like i got no problem look i
go to the store i'll wear masks whatever
that's different then they're gonna
start saying dude just get the vacs man
it's no big deal
and so they're going to make everyone
get the vaccine i mean in some places
they've already done it so i'm not
trying to like be conspiratorial like oh
the mandatory vaccination is coming
there's there have been uh i think in
australia you can't travel outside of
the country unless you've been
vaccinated something like that
in denmark they're protesting a law
right now they've been protesting for
like 10 or 11 days
man a law that includes a provision for
mandatory vaccination and forced
physical examinations
so probably a good thing to protest
because that's
freaky well here's what i think it'll
come here i do what if
it doesn't mutate every year like the
flu let's say so every year you have to
get a new vaccination
or is that gas is that the plan i don't
know i don't have a plan
we don't know i don't know anything
about this we have a great reset plan
that's true
i don't take away all your stuff i mean
maybe a state will be like you can't
come in if you didn't get the vaccine
but that'd be like the governor made
that decision and then the people would
riot
on the governor i think we're going to
see riots again i think the riots we saw
this year in june were a product uh
a bit of being locked up for so long
dude there's so much data
of recovery rates for kovid that people
would go insane if they tried to
do some forced dude look at like we were
just talking about people cheering for
trunan on a shot of the pressure
the mindless yeah maybe maybe that was
part what what if trinidad shabbat of
pressure was actually in joe biden's
like uh teleprompter and it was them
being like okay
if they cheer for this we can do
anything
and so biden is like you know what
people don't realize mine's actually
sharp as attack right
he was actually able to read true not
shop at a pressure on the teleprompter
as it moves up give me something crazy
that took me a long time to transcribe
to get it just right trinidad a shop at
a pressure
and so for him to be able to read it off
real quick what was it again true
international cooperation cooperation i
don't know if that's i'm just
no idea true international cooperation
under pressure
and what's batacath care healthcare what
was that
obamacare
okay that's the point if you've got 77
million people or whatever in this
country
and a large portion are such zealots
that they'll cheer when when joe biden
says
garbled nonsense just wants someone to
be trump they're going to be like
drink this substance from under my
basement upstairs and you can come into
my restaurant
zealots aren't necessarily the kovitz
zealots they are
well not necessarily there there might
be some overlapping heavy overlap
so we were talking to michael malus on
the show and
it was on the show we mentioned what is
it how do you determine left or right
yeah yeah
no i think it was before the show was it
yeah i think so oh okay
was it like it was on the show yeah yeah
it was okay okay he said i made a speech
yeah that's right
right you started yeah yeah he said uh
how do you figure out someone's on the
left or right you ask them
do you think some people are better than
others and the right will say yes
and the left will give you a speech i
was like defined better yeah yeah i
think
i think that's what i said to you yeah
there's an easier way to do it
it's to ask someone are they scared of
covid
and for the most part the right's going
to be like no you know i get it it's you
know
a lot of people will be like a lot of
the like the the you know the die-hard
guys are going to be like
no way man i don't have to wear a man i
can do whatever i want then you're gonna
get the more moderate people who are
gonna say look i get it
it's like it's got lingering health
effects it's serious i'll wear my mask
but i'm not gonna go cry i'm gonna you
know carry on with my life the left
that you look at the gallup polls from
this it's like something like 70
of republicans are like we're kind of
concerned about this and
uh five percent of democrats are like
we're kind of concerned
the rest of them are like it's the end
like 95 of democrats are freaking out
over this i
i respect and fear to appoint dangerous
pathogens
and things i completely because they can
ravage animals
quickly but there's so much evidence
that covet has what 99.9
99.9 now that's even more uh recovery
rate so it's like people are getting it
unless you're over 70 or have a
comorbidity then it's 90 uh 97.5 and
that's because of the combat 97 points
that's still
great for someone with comorbidity
that's old that's a high death rate
though that's like you know a couple
percent three points is seriously
but those people were already ill a lot
of those are they're over seven years in
the community right right right they
have comorbidities and when you see
numbers like that i'm just not
concerned i'm not even concerned so you
know what's weird i'm sorry no go ahead
good
it's a weird reversal because weren't
conservatives considered the types to be
like putting up fences closing their
doors putting
like turtles going into their shell
right protective
whereas now we're seeing liberals saying
no now we have to
or leftists i should say now we have to
put our shells on and close up
and conservatives are saying let's open
up and check this out
in minnesota in the iron range two
long time uh like leaders in the
democratic party have quit
it's the democratic farmer labor party
or whatever they call the democratic
party up in minnesota
they quit and they said because we want
to make a more moderate bipartisan
you know uh party or whatever in caucus
so the republicans are like glad to hear
it
because the democrats have gone nuts in
minnesota the democrats
gained areas that were typically
republican affluent suburbs
and trump gained in the working-class
areas and that's so weird
it's a flip the the the democratic party
has become the party of the wealthy
elites and the managerial elites
and the moral authoritarians and the
republican parties become the party of
not completely but the shift is
happening blue collar-ish blue-collar
just regular working people that's weird
because i'll go through
neighborhoods around where i live and i
see a lot of mansions with the biden
signs and then i see
a lot of like carpenter types of people
uh people who work with their hands
they love trump right blue collar people
we're living in backwards land it's
flipped i don't know what's going on
with 2020.
you look at you look at like the ultra
woke people that's typically like a
wealthy
they're typically upper class
progressive they have a lot to lose
if the rioters come down their street
they have a lot of those interesting
i think the flip is coming it's getting
crazier and crazier and maybe
that's all that needs to happen and
there's not going to be some like
chaotic civil war or something
but my my bigger fear is is trump
if we get to a point where there is some
kind of court certification for trump
giving him a legal justification to say
he won and then biden refuses to admit
defeat
and i think it's very likely hillary
clinton said joe biden should not
concede under any circumstances
now to be real like realistic trump is
the one who is protected to lose right
now i'm not trying to do this dude but
like but hillary can still win
no but trump is still suing and there's
still these like really narrow paths
where he might actually figure something
out
and if he does joe biden's not gonna
back down i'm worried about whether
if this is a silly chess game let's say
there's only so many ways that could go
if things turn violent
you get the military involved that
creates bad optics which creates more
anti-authoritarian sentiment which
creates more violence
right exactly there's no good outcome
for that
if i was the type of person who says
that's what i want chaotic situations
where
they're begging for the government the
right is going to be begging for the
government to intercede
which looks bad and is bad because
you're going to see people getting their
heads caved in by like police officers
who are angry or
national guard or something like that on
the other hand if you just let the
rioters go crazy like they have been
who knows what kind of damage is going
to be done people are going to be scared
to go outside
we're sort of backing ourselves because
the temperature is so high
we're all backing ourselves into these
bad corners where there's really no way
out except
either bad optics people getting their
heads caved in violence
i wish this this could be solved on a
legislative level on let's use our words
but everybody seems to be so scared of
the other side and
in some cases for good reason i don't
want to talk to somebody who's coming at
me with like a shield and a thing in
their hand like
bro put it down thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you